why are you using the toothbrush well
I'm sorry I didn't even in this or are
you going to stop that's disgusting
it's like the same thing no it's not yes
stop it that's not how I felt stop what
I'm not sorry that happened
you can't just tickle people to get
whatever you want it's weird that I even
have to say that 5:45 you can't just
typical people to get whatever you want
weird that I even have to say that
at the toothbrush
did you hurt no no IIIi tickled people
hi I went a little overboard I'll admit
but come on yeah you gotta go what I'm
not trying to go to jail this is weird
this is gonna be the last time you see
me okay you take that toothbrush cuz I
don't need it
hey now you have two toothbrushes it's a
very weird ass
not even Ivy League no experience or
training even a remotely suited for this
job I can say without a doubt that you
would never and I mean never work for my
corporation you don't take no for an
answer kid I like that
Oh God
I really wanted to give you these I
don't want everything sucks there dude
you're a mess I need to talk to Mike
that's right okay
it doesn't mean that we're under arrest
robbery credit that bogan assault LAPD
[ __ ] what Jen did you do this
yes I thought I wasn't gonna go to jail
you're just a weird guy
hey wait you guys solved my purse Hey